- We really had to
produce an actual event
and then shoot at it.
- [Director] Hold.
- I...
quit.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, welcome to
The Other Show, I'm Sarah.
- And I'm Chris.
- And we're here talking
about episode two
of The Other Two
with Drew and Helene.
- Yay!
(everyone talking
over each other)
- So this episode is
Chase Goes To A Premiere.
- Hey cuties, I'm about
to hit the red carpet
with my manager, Streeter.
Say what's up, Streeter.
- Wazzup!
- So this episode, a lot
of our season takes place
at big events for Chase and
this is the first one of those
where we had to produce
a movie premiere
and then we shot
our episode at it.
- It was unbelievable.
- We just wanted it
to feel legitimate,
Because we wanted to
help legitimize Chase
and the world that these
two doofs are entering.
- You know how like in
real life, you're gay?
- Yes.
- Well, the Ad guys loved
that, in fact one of the guys
wanted me to tell you that
his brother is also gay.
- Cool?
- [Agent] But the thing is,
they think that the
character is straight.
- More than 12 years ago
I went in for an audition,
I don't even know
what it was for,
but all I had to do, I
didn't have any lines,
I just had to pantomime
laying fertilizer.
I just had to mime laying
fertilizer and say no lines,
and then when I was
done they were like,
"That was great,
that was great."
So I think this is sort of like,
a suburban guy, think
he's got a wife,
so I was trying to
get a little more,
basically saying a
little straighter
(Drew laughs)
without saying it,
and I was like,
how do I mime laying
fertilizer straighter?
Though, I can see was
probably pretty gay.
(everyone laughs)
So I was like, what do I do?
So then I just did it again
but I was sort of like...
(Chris grunts repeatedly)
And I just coughed and cleared
my throat because I was like,
I guess a straight person would
cough more while he did it.
And then I got it and I've
been in those commercials
for years, you've seen it.
(everyone laughs)
It's played for comedy that
you had to re-shoot this
audition and do it less gay
but then at the very end
where you feel guilty that you
allowed yourself to do that.
- Yeah, you kinda see
Cary sort of dealing with
internalized
homophobia at the end
with the waiter being like,
oh, no, no, no, for me it was
just, they wanted it louder,
I've dealt with
that in real life,
where you're self-hatey.
Being a queer actor,
you're trying to get,
navigate this world that's
a very difficult area
that you make missteps
in and it's like...
- Well, it's like, what do
other people want you be?
But then regardless of what
they want, will I allow myself
to change because of
what I think people want?
- I feel for Cary.
(Drew stutters)
I feel for Cary.
He's in a tough, because you're
like, oh, I need this money,
I'm gonna throw
myself out the window.
- No, I like that it never
occurred to him when his agent
was like, do it again, less gay.
He's like, okay, that's
what you gotta do
and then you're like, oh, duh.
(Chris groans)
It is...
rough.
- It's so sad!
Your daddy's...
dead!
(Brylyn weeps)
- My daddy's dead?
- Kate Simses plays Brylyn.
We really, going into casting,
couldn't tell if we
should cast young
and make them look
older or cast older
and just be like, they're 11.
I guess we didn't know what
was gonna work comedically.
- Kate made me laugh so hard,
it was so hard to
keep a straight face
when she was going into like,
bursting into tears
about my daddy being dead
and her face was just so,
like she was so deeply,
and even in-between takes,
Kate is such a sweet person
that the whole picture
was just unbelievable.
- Yeah, because the idea of
that character is very broad
or almost sketchy
so we were trying
to make sure it's
still grounded,
but she was so good and like,
so funny but still real even
though it was so preposterous.
She's great, I loved her.
- Brooke, thank god.
- Here.
- This party is not fun.
- Yes it is.
I'm having fun.
- This episode also has my
favorite unspoken joke in it,
which is: you get
drinks for you and Cary
and you guys meet back
together and you give him
the little pink martini glass
and you drink the whiskey,
which is what Chris and I do
and we often order those things
and then get delivered
them opposite
and then we silently switch.
- [Male Voice] Ho ho,
great party, dude.
- It is a great party.
Glad you're having fun, man.
- [Male Voice] Oh, I'm...
No, no, I'm uh...
I'm auditioning
for a commercial.
- The fun thing about
that fart commercial is
this is the third
time it's been written
because we tried it
twice at SNL as a sketch.
We tried it once with Paul Rudd
and once with Julia
Louis-Dreyfus.
- It went really
well at the table
and then at dress
rehearsal it ate shit.
- Died.
- Because the whole
sketch was predicated
on him making very
small fart smells,
so it's very subtle
and small and just
a huge audience,
it's not gonna work.
And then we were like, well,
we'll try it again with
Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
and it got pulled,
it didn't work again.
And we were like, you know what?
You know what this is missing?
Drew Tarver.
(everyone talking
over each other)
- Julia couldn't make it, Paul
Rudd couldn't make it work.
[Drew] I make it work.
(upbeat music)